one thing one thing only killing Nazis
so you want to make a brad pitt fill
well you came to the right place
being a critically acclaimed artist
winning the sexiest man alive award
multiple times and having married
Jennifer Aniston and Angelina Jolie is a
pretty high bar to meet but if you can
reach it you can make films where you
are basically portrayed as Jesus that
doesn't mean much to anyone
seems yours might mean a lot to a whole
lot of people confidence is key when you
walk into a scene make sure your
presence is know if other people are in
the scene with you make sure you jostle
them and joke around maybe even throw
some fake punches and laughs it doesn't
matter if the people you are laughing
with know why they're laughing you just
have to be confident enough that they
follow along you're going to need to
laugh a lot at weird times and at things
that aren't really very funny yeah
well the most important things about
making a Brad Pitt movie is to do
everything you do in the most badass way
possible
hanging up your coat make it cool
dancing in your car make it really cool
eating a burger make it the slickest
King burger eating to ever occur
speaking of eating oral fixation is
essential chewing slurping biting
nibbling sipping scarfing crunching and
gnawing is your largest tool and your
battle to be an a-list actor never
pulled that must have had about 50
sweetheart will you pass the song well
maybe we can hook a wall on a goldfish
accessible system I've seen but it's
always have a nice trip
hey five exterior the whole tux
we can't tell the whole I said the words
general meant goodbye that tour fifty
million dollars is this how do you
choose your roles well all you have to
do is ask yourself this very simple
question will I look like a badass when
I kill someone as this character
I think this just mountain on
masterpiece now a great way to add flair
to your characters is to give them an
accent unfortunately although you might
try many different accents you can never
really land one is that no one else
that's why any and every sumbitch we
find wearing a Nazi uniform they're
gonna die that morning I was not yet a
vampire and I saw my last sunrise I see
this unfair advantage you got you got a
too much metal going here I told you I
warned ya
davin but I look at all that and that's
it follow these very simple instructions
and you'll be on your way to creating
your very own Brad Pitt Phil I felt like
Freddy's a barge back and wrap me up to
caption window friends and eating them
yes eating them okay there we go